Hi. I'm Peter Norvig, and I'll be teaching  "the Design of Computer Programs" or CS212.
This class is a follow up to CS101, or the equivalent
in this class you will learn how to look at the description of a problem
and come up with a good solution.
You will learn that there are many choices along the way
and that some of these choices are just a matter of taste
and other choices have important repercussions.
In short this class is about setting you on the path
to developing good taste as a programmer.
I hope you'll join me.
"You said on your blog that it can take 10 years to be
an expert programmer. What can students learn in 7 weeks?
That's a great question. If you want to be
a world-class expert at anything, whether it's computer programming
playing the violin, basketball, whatever, it is going to take years.
But, that just means it's a great time to get started now.
And if you're deliberative and think about what you're doing
and keep on practicing, you can make a lot of progress
in as short a time as seven weeks.
CS212: The design of computer programs.
Taught by Professor Peter Norvig